الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
يستعد اليوم ليصبح اول رئيس امريكي سابق
او ما زال في السلطه توجه اليه اتهامات
جنائيه ترامب سيصل الى المحكمه وسينبغي
عليه الخضوع لنفس الاجراءات التي يخضع لها
جميع الاشخاص الذين يستدعيهم القضاء مثل
الكشف عن اسمه وعمره ومهنته واخذ بصماته
والتقاط صوره له تعرف باسم مكشات فما هي
هذه الصوره التي ستخلد في سيرات ترامب
الذاتيه الى الابد
المكشوط مصطلح غير رسمي لصوره الشرطه او
صوره الحجز وهي صوره فوتوغرافيه للمتهم من
الكتفين الى الاعلى وعاده ما يتم التقاطها
بعد القبض على الشخص لكن هذه الصوره تمثل
مصدر خصيه للنجوم والمشاهير الذين يتم
توقيفهم بدات تصوير المجرمين في اربعانيات
القرن التاسع عشر الى ان قام ضابط فرنسي
يدعى الفونس باختيلون عام 1900 بتطوير هذه
العمليه وتوحيد طريقه التصوير تتكون
المكشوت من صورتين واحده من الامام واخرى
من منظر جانبي للمتهم مع خلفيه واضحه
لتجنب تشتيت الانتباه كما يطلب احيانا من
الشخص الموقوف ان يحمل لافته تحمل الاسم
وتاريخ الميلاد ورقم المتهم
رغم الانتباه السلبي الذي تتركه المكشوت
على المتهم الا ان تقارير اعلاميه تقول ان
ترامب ربما يستغل هذه الصوره بشكل واسع في
حمله تسويقيه كبيره زعمه لموقفه في سباق
الرئاسي الذي ينوي ترامب خوله عام 2024